ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
TODAY'S TUESDAY MARCH TWENTY
SECONDS WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE CAN START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE LITTLE BIT OF
BUSINESS FIRST. WHILE THEY'RE NO
MORE CAPACITY LIMITS OR
REQUIREMENTS FOR PHYSICAL
DISTANCING FOR OUR HEARINGS WE
STILL ARE IN A TIME OF PANDEMIC
SO FOR EVERYONE'S SAFETY WE DO
ASK THAT FOLKS DO MAINTAIN
DISTANCE. MASKING IS NOT
REQUIRED BUT IS ENCOURAGED. WE
HAVE TWO DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY
CERTAINLY HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM NOW BUT ALSO BY PHONE. SO
IF YOU'RE IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME AND WE DO ASK THAT. THOSE
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE THE SERGEANTS WILL
HANDLE THAT FOR YOU FOR MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC WHO WISH TO COMMENT
VIA TELEPHONE. THE NUMBERS. THE
PHONE NUMBER THE ACCESS CODE
SHOULD BE UP ON YOUR SCREEN. BUT
THE TOLL FREE CALL IN NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN
THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. AGAIN THAT IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN THERE
SHOULD BE UP ON YOUR SCREEN. SO
WE'RE GOING TO START AGAIN AS A
SUB COMMITTEE SOME OF A REALLY.
YOU HAVE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR WITH US. GOOD MORNING THE
MORNING ITS SHARE. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS- TODAY
I'M EXCEPT I AM. PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR FIRST I AM ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON.
THIS BILL WHICH INCLUDES WORKING
WITH THE CITY OF SAN JOSE AND MY
OFFICE ACROSS THIS BILL EARLY
THE AMENDMENTS ADDED THE
DEFINITION FOR SMALL BUSINESS
AND INFORMATION ABOUT PHYSICAL
ACCESSIBILITY IMPROVEMENTS THE
LIST OF INFORMATION CITIES AND
COUNTIES PROVIDE TO RELEVANT
AGENCIES THIS BILL AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR WELL IN HIS CREASE
COMPLIANCE WITH DISABILITY
ACCESS LAWS BY ENSURING SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN ACCESS FUNDS. TO
MAKE NECESSARY IMPROVEMENTS AND
INCREASE THE ACCESSIBILITY OF
THEIR BUSINESS THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT THE ACCESSIBILITY THE
ACCESSIBILITY COMPLIANCE FUND AS
A STEADY STREAM OF MONEY FLOWING
INTO IT TO HELP BUSINESSES
COMPLY WITH SUCH REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL ALSO EXPANDS THE
ALLOWABLE USES OF THESE FUNDS
INCLUDE FUNDING TO MAKE PHYSICAL
IMPROVEMENTS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE COMPETING COMPLIANCE WITH
ADA LOS. AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR ALLOWS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO CONTINUE. THEIR WORK MAKING
CALIFORNIA ACCESSIBLE WHY
SUPPORT WHILE SUPPORTING SMALL
BUSINESSES. I WOULD LIKE TO
CONCLUDE BY ALSO THINKING
CALCHAMBER AND DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA FOR THE STRONG
SUPPORT AND WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH OUR OFFICE TO FIND A
SOLUTION THAT WORKS FOR THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY WHILE ALSO
PRESERVING AND PROTECTING
ACCESSIBILITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I WITH ME TODAY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT BUT THE
PHONES WILL BE THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE VICE MAYOR CHAPPIE JONES.
AND DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY ERIC
HARRIS ARE STRICTLY A STRIPE OF.
THANK YOU MISTER LEE SO I DO
HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT CHARLES JONES. ON THE
TELEPHONE AND ERIC HARRIS AND
THE TELEPHONE MISTER JONES ARE
YOU WITH US. YES I AM IN THE
MORNING CARE STONE AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
JACKIE JONES AND I AM THE VICE
MAYOR OF THE CITY TELL DAY. AND
WE'RE PROUD TO BE SPONSORED AB.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEX LEE. AS
CHAIR SMALL BUSINESSES FIVE
THREE CATS ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
COME UP WITH LEADERS THROUGHOUT
THE CITY. AND SOME FEEDBACK OF
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO OUR
CITY COUNCIL. ON HOW WE CAN BEST
HELP. THE CITY SMALL BUSINESSES.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON DISABILITY ACCESS
ANNUAL REPORT. FAILED THEY HAD
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF REPORTED
ALLEGED DISABILITY ACCESS
VIOLATIONS. ACROSS THE STATE.
IT'S THAT POPPING TO THE CLOSURE
OF PARSONS BUSINESS. PRIMARILY
TO LIMITED ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
RESOURCES OR KNOWLEDGE ON HOW TO
COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OR
CORRECT VIOLATIONS. ULTIMATELY
WE HAVE TO ENSURE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT IS ACCEPTABLE
INCLUDES TOP ALL OF OUR MEMBERS
. AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR
SUPPORT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BY
CHRISTINE FUNDING TO IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY ARE REDUCED BY
REMOVING THE SUNSET DATE. ON THE
FOUR DOLLAR FEE DEFINITELY
CLARIFIES THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO USE THOSE FUNDS
THE GRANT. WHILE BUSINESSES. THE
IT WILL BE FUN. SO THEY CAN HAVE
. RELATED SEARCHES. THE BY
CONSTRUCTION IT PERMITTED FEES
FORTY FIVE RESPECTFUL URGE TO
VOTE I AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AND THEN ERICA. THE MORE SURE
MEMBER MY NAME IS ERIC TERROR
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR PUBLIC ALL
AT THIS BILL YOU WRITE%
CALIFORNIA I'M TESTIFYING TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
LEE THERE ARE SEVERAL REASONS
WHY CALIFORNIA SHOULD PRIORITIZE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR THE DISABILITY
POPULATION. FIRST THE DISABILITY
POPULATION IS ESTIMATED TO BE
BETWEEN 2533% OF ADULTS AND MOST
BELIEVE THOSE ARE LOW ESTEEM. WE
ARE ALL LIVING LONGER AND PEOPLE
ARE GETTING MORE AND MORE
DISABILITIES AS B. H. NEXT
DISABLED PEOPLE OUR CUSTOMERS
AND EMPLOYEES AND WANT TO BE
ABLE TO ENJOY BUSINESSES. AND
THE CITY THAT THEY LIVE AND
VISIT. NEXT CUSTOMERS AND
EMPLOYEES WHO DO NOT HAVE
DISABILITIES MIGHT HAVE FRIENDS
WHO HAVE DISABILITIES. AND
FINALLY WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT
ANYONE CAN DEVELOP A DISABILITY
AT ANY TIME IT ISCRUCIAL THAT
WE STRIVE TO BE MORE INCLUDES A
MORE COHESIVE STATE FOR ALL
PEOPLE WITH ALL TYPES OF
DISABILITIES. THESE REASONS WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE TO
OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. THIS COME
FORTH. AT THIS POINT WE WANT TO
BE TAKEN MORE TESTIMONY BUT WILL
TAKE NAME AFFILIATION. AND
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHAIR STONE DERRICK
SEAVER A PRESIDENCY OR THE SAME
AS A CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE.
THANK YOU KNOW ALL THOSE
AMERICAN BUSINESS OWNER. TAKING
L. C. IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE HERO. ALL
RIGHT SIGNAL OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR.
BUT IN THE GENERAL DATA CAN
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR PRESS ONE ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE'S KEYPAD. AMPLE FIRST
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CARE
MEMBERS THIS IS JULIE MALINOWSKI
BOTTLE WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA
HOTEL AND LODGING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. NEXT IN LINE TWENTY ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
SHERRY MEMBERS THIS IS ACTUALLY
HOW OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MR JOURNAL
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE. ANY
LISTED IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR. I'D SAY NOT OPERATED
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO THE COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR PRESS ONE ZERO POINTS. DEMONSTRATOR WILL KNOW
COMMENTERS AND KEEP. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS MR
THE MACKLOWE. I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE- BUSINESS COALITION
AND THE DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA FOR SPRING THIS BILL
AND FOR MY CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
PRESIDENT FOR COMING ALL THE WAY
UP TO SACRAMENTO TO TESTIFY AS
WELL. REALLY HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL PASS THIS BILL
BECAUSE I CERTAINLY THINK WE
NEED TO INCREASE COMPLIANCE WITH
pENJOYABLE ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS ABSOLUTELY- DRIVER.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL TAKE A
MOTION ON THAT ONCE WE GET A
QUORUM THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE SEEM TO HAVE A DEARTH
OF AUTHORS AS WELL AS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SO I GUESS WILL BE ON A
BIT OF A POSITIVE- FOLKS SHOW UP.
THIS REYES WHO ALSO HAVE A BILL
WOULD YOU LIKE 2% GOOD TIMING SO
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY WHICH WILL
AUTHORIZE THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO
ESTABLISH A VOLUNTARY COMPLIANCE
PROGRAM TO INCREASE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY LAW. I WOULD DO WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND FOR STRENGTHENING
THE BILL SO WE'RE BETTER ABLE TO
BRING OUR HOLDERS INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW. WHILE
THE STATE HAS ESTABLISHED THE-
PROCESS TO RECLAIM UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY AS OF TWENTY TWENTY
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT THREE
MILLION BUSINESSES. WHO FILE
THEIR TAXES FAILED TO INCLUDE
WITH THEIR TAXES THE UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY REPORT. IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LAW WE ESTIMATE THAT'S
ABOUT SEVENTEEN POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY THAT TWEET
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE HAS NOT
RECEIVED. IT'S DUE TO A
COMBINATION OF A NUMBER OF
THINGS INCLUDING A LACK OF
AWARENESS OF THE EXISTING LAW
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
REPORTING AND THE POTENTIAL
PRIVACY CONCERNS. THE UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY LAW WAS PASSED TO
PROVIDE CITIZENS AWAY TO CHECK
TO SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY OR FOR THE
ERRORS TO CHECK ON. PROPERTY
THAT TO THE STATE HAS TAKEN.
EVEN THOUGH BUSINESSES HAVE THE
THREAT OF AN AUDIT OR ALSO THE
12% INTEREST THE COULD BE
ASSESSED ON UNCLAIMED PROPERTY-
WE FIND THAT IT IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO COMPEL THEM TO
PREPARE THE REPORT. AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY IS GOING TO INCREASE
COMPLIANCE BY DOING A NUMBER OF
THINGS FIRST IT WILL AUTHORIZE
THE STATE COMPTROLLER TO
ESTABLISH A VOLUNTARY COMPLIANCE
PROGRAM. IT'LL ALLOW THE
CONTROLLER TO WAIT INTEREST
PENALTIES OTHERWISE DO UNDER THE
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY LAW IF A
BUSINESS COMPLETE AN EDUCATION
PROGRAM SEARCHES THEIR BOOKS.
AND IT SEARCHES THE BOOKS AND
RECORDS FOR UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
AND THEN TIMELY REPORTS AND
DELIVERS THE PROPERTY UNCOVERED
TO THE CONTROLLER. BAR THEY CAN
ALSO BAR THIRD PARTY SERVICES
THE PROMISED TO RECOVER AND
CLICK PROPERTIES ON BEHALF OF
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FROM
CHARGING UP FRONT FEES. NO HERE
TO TESTIFY. OF TODAY ARE INDIRA.
MCDONALD'S AND GILLIAN NIGHT
FROM THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU I THINK I HAVE
THE MEDICAID ON THE TELEPHONE
BUT THE AMENDMENTS JUST FOR THE
RECORD YOU ARE TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS AS AUTHORS OF THANK
YOU WE ARE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
AND THANK YOU FOR CATCHING THAT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO I DO HAVE
IN YOUR MATERNAL AND JULIAN
KNIGHT BOTH WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE INTERMITTENT. GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY MY NAME
IS LINDA MCDONALD WITH THE
OFFICE OF STATE CONTROLLER
BETTY. I WITH ME AS DALY AT
NIGHT AND SHE WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. I
THINK CONTROLLER BETTY IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
VOLUNTARY COMPLIANCE PROGRAM. I
BUSINESS OWNERS THAT ARE HOLDERS
OF UNCLAIMED PROPERTY ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT REMAIN
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY WHEN THERE
HAS BEEN NO ACTIVITY OR CONTACT
WITH THE OWNER FOR A SPECIFIED
PERIOD OF. TIME WE ESTIMATE OVER
A MILLION BUSINESSES HAVE FAILED
TO REPORT AN COULD BE HOLDING AN
EXCESS OF SEVENTEEN POINT SIX
BILLION AN UNCLAIMED PROPERTY.
THE LACK OF COMPLIANCE MAY BE
DUE IN PART. TO A LACK OF
AWARENESS OF EXISTING LAWS AND
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
REPORTING ARE OUTDATED REPORTING
PROCEDURES. EITHER WE'RE NETWORK
HOLDER THE BEYOND COMPARE HOT
LAST YEAR CONTROLLER SPOT
LEGISLATION THAT WAS ENACTED TO
PROVIDE FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO ASK QUESTIONS TO THE
CORPORATE TAX FORMS ABOUT
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY LOSS. AND
EITHER VOLUNTARY QUESTIONS FOR
BUSINESSES TO ANSWER ON THE TAX
FORM AND THIS INFORMATION
INFORMS US ABOUT- HOLDERS WHO
ARE MOST RECEPTIVE TO OUR
EDUCATION OUTREACH. AND THIS
BILL IS THE NEXT STEP TO
PROVIDING HOLDERS WHO MAY BE
FIRST TIME FILERS ARE WHO WHO
MAY BE UNAWARE OF THE LOT- OR
INTIMIDATED BY IT THIS IS THE
PROGRAM TO FOR THEM TO COME
FORWARD- AND- UNDER THE
VOLUNTARY COMPLIANCE PROGRAM
WHERE WE WILL PROVIDE TRAINING
TO THEM AND THE TOOLS NECESSARY
FOR THE HOLDERS. TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH A LOT. I'M BIT
SO THIS ARE UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE COMPTROLLER DOES ADMINISTER
THIS PROGRAM THE END OF THE
PROGRAM BUT EXISTING LAW DOES
NOT EXPLICITLY GRANT HER THE
AUTHORITY TO CREATE AND
ADMINISTER THAT. PARTICULAR
PROGRAM AND SO WE ARE VERY HAPPY
TO I AM PLEASED TO SPONSOR
EVENTS- IT WILL ESTABLISH THE
PROGRAM AND ENABLE THE
CONTROLLER TO WAIVE PENALTY
INTEREST FOR PAST DUE PROPERTY
AS REPORTED BY HOLDERS THAT
VOLUNTARILY ENROLLED- ARE
ACCEPTED AND SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETE THE PROGRAM- AND IT
WILL INCLUDE. A DEFINITELY
INCREASED A MORE PUBLIC
AWARENESS- SO THAT HOLDER CAN
GET INTO COMPLIANCE ADDITIONALLY
AT THE BILL ENHANCES CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS BY ENSURING
CLAIMANTS OF PERSONAL
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION IS
SHIELDED FROM PUBLIC DISCLOSURE.
AND PREVENTING- AGGRESSIVE THIRD
PARTY AYE INVESTIGATORS FROM
CHARGING UP FRONT FEES I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TESTIFIED AND I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTION. THANK YOU
AND AS YOU SAID JULIAN KNIGHT IS
ALSO AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
THAT IS THAT'S CORRECT. EXACTLY
WE CAN WE CAN RESPOND TO ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAP PERFECT THANK YOU.
RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE TO. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO LIKED INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE STRUCTURE WE HAVE
NO COMMENT IS QUEUED UP THANK
YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
LISTED BUT IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WHICH OPEN
ALLIANCE FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO. SPEAKING OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY. TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MR JOURNAL COMMENTERS HAVE
QUEUED UP THANK YOU AND I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. I WOULD HAVE
THAT WE DON'T KNOW QUORUM YET SO
WE CANNOT TAKE A MOTION RIGHT
MADAM MAJORITY LEADER YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR- AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
WILL TAKE A MOTION WHEN WE GET
ENOUGH PEOPLE FOR THAT- FROM.
THANK YOU RIGHT MISTER GREG ITEM
NUMBER THREE. AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY EIGHTHS. GOOD MORNING MORE
GERMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO. SIXTY
EIGHT. I THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
MEMBERS THAT WOULD RENAME THE
MERCED SUPERIOR COURTHOUSE IN
HONOR OF PROFESSOR CHARLES JAMES
OGLETREE JUNIOR. FOR VERY HUMBLE
BEGINNINGS IN MERCED PROFESSOR
OGLETREE EMBARKED ON A PROLIFIC
CAREER FOCUSED ON THE
ADVANCEMENT OF CIVIL RIGHTS
RACIAL JUSTICE AND SOCIAL
TOLERANCE. IN ADDITION TO HIS
INFLUENTIAL WRITINGS IS A LEGAL
SCHOLAR. PROFESSOR OGLETREE
INSPIRED GENERATIONS OF LAW
STUDENTS AS A PROFESSOR AT
HARVARD INCLUDING. FORMER
PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY BARACK
AND MICHELLE OBAMA. AS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY PROFESSOR OGLETREE
NOTABLY REPRESENTED SURVIVORS OF
THE NINETEEN TWENTY ONE TULSA
RACE MASSACRE AND ACTED AS LEGAL
COUNSEL TO PROFESSOR ANITA HILL
DURING THE CLARENCE THOMAS
SENATE CONFIRMATION HEARINGS. HE
RECEIVED COUNTLESS PRESTIGIOUS
AWARDS THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER
INCLUDING BEING NAMED ONE OF THE
ONE HUNDRED MOST INFLUENTIAL
LAWYERS IN AMERICA BY THE
NATIONAL LAW JOURNAL. AND BOTH
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL UC MERCED
HAVE ESTABLISHED ENDOWED
POSITIONS NAMED IN HIS HONOR.
PROFESSOR OGLETREE FOUNDED THE
CHARLES HAMILTON HOUSTON
INSTITUTE FOR RACE AND JUSTICE
IN HONOR OF THE LEGENDARY CIVIL
RIGHTS LWYER AND MENTOR TO SUCH
INFLUENTIAL FIGURES AS THURGOOD
MARSHALL AND OLIVER HILL. HE'S
BEEN A THOUGHT LEADER PUSHING
THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION ON
RACE AND JUSTICE FORWARD
INCLUDING AS A LAWYER
COMMENTATOR PROFESSOR AND AUTHOR
OF SUCH WORKS AS LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE. AMERICA'S NEW BETH TALLY
IN THE ROAD TO ABOLITION THE
FUTURE OF CAPITAL PUNISHMENT IN
THE UNITED STATES. AS ONE OF
MERCED COUNTY'S PROUDEST NATIVE
SONS WHO IS MADE INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTIONS TOWARD THE
ADVANCEMENT OF RACIAL JUSTICE
THE AMERICAN LEGAL SYSTEM
THERE'S NO MORE DESERVING
INDIVIDUAL ON WHOM TO BESTOW
DISHONOR THE PROFESSOR OGLETREE
. DESPITE THE INDISPUTABLE
GROUND BREAKING CONTRIBUTIONS
MADE BY PROFESSOR OGLETREE THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S COURTHOUSE
NAMING POLICY. PROHIBITS THE
NAMING OF THE MERCED COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURTHOUSE IN HIS
HONOR. THE POLICY ONLY PERMITS
THE NAME OF COURTHOUSES FOR
PERSONS WHO ARE DECEASED AND
HAVE BEEN SO FOR AT LEAST TEN
YEARS. AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY EIGHT
WOULD CREATE AN EXEMPTION THIS
POLICY TO CREATE CHARLES JAMES
OGLETREE JUNIOR COURTHOUSE. AS
NOTED BY THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THERE ARE CURRENTLY TWENTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA COURTHOUSES THAT BEEN
NAMED IN HONOR OF AN INDIVIDUAL
WITH THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
NAME FOR WHITE MEN. AS A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM RE
EXAMINES PRACTICES THAT RESULTED
IN THE OVER INCARCERATION OF
MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND IN
PARTICULAR BLACK MAN IT WOULD BE
FITTING FOR MORE JUDGES TO
CONDUCT THEIR WORK. IN
FACILITIES NAME FOR LEADERS LIKE
PROFESSOR OGLETREE. ON THE PHONE
I HAVE TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ALLEN BROOKS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE MERCED COUNTY AND DOUBLE
ACP. AS WELL AS DOMINIQUE
DINETTE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HAWAII CHAPTER OF THE N. DOUBLE
ACP- THIS CHAIR IF YOUR PERMIT
WILL- TURNED OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES THANK YOU MISTER GRAY
SO I DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES ALLEN
BROOKS AND DOMINIQUE DOT NET.
ALLEN BROOKS ARE YOU WITH US.
OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE ALLEN
BROOKS ON THE LINE. WE DO NOT
HAVE A LONG BOOKS ON THE
SPEAKERS LINE MALAM WORKS IF YOU
ARE IN A LISTEN ONLY ONE PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO SEVEN FIVE. THIS
WHICH I DON'T BELIEVE IT MISTER
BROOKS CONNECTED HOW ABOUT
DOMINICK DUNNE AT. DOMENIC IS
HERE OKAY GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CARE AND NUMBERS MY
NAME IS DOMINIQUE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HAWAII
STATE CONFERENCE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR THE ADVANCEMENT
OF COLORED PEOPLE I'M HERE SURE
STRONG SUPPORT AB TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT THREE NAME THE SUPERIOR
COURTHOUSE AND RESPECT COUNTY.
DR CHARLES JAMES OGLETREE JUNIOR
COURTHOUSE COMPUTER CRAP
CALIFORNIA THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR THE ADVANCEMENT
OF COLORED PEOPLE WISE AND STILL
REMAINS THE LARGEST AND MOST
INFLUENTIAL COVERAGE OR
INDICATIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES. WHERE AN ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND HAVE FOUGHT
TIRELESSLY TAP WITH THE LIVES OF
BLACK. PEOPLE AND OTHER PEOPLE
OF COLOR. WE HONOR THOSE WHO
DIED CONTAIN TO DO THAT WORK. DR
CHARLES OGLETREE EGGS.
EVERYTHING I OR- FANS. I HAVE
GREAT. CAREER HE ON ADVANCEMENT
THAT WERE. RACIAL JUSTICE AND
PUSH TOLERANCE. THE WORK OF THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER PROFESSOR OF LAW
AUTHOR AND MUCH MUCH MORE. ASK
STATED IT WOULD BE FITTING FOR
MORE JUDGES TO CONDUCT THEIR
WORK AND FACILITIES KERRY AND
JUST THE THOUGHT. LEADERS LIKE
DR OGLETREE. I BE HAPPY TO COME
HAWAII AND OTHER ACP. I WANT TO
THANK THE GREAT GREAT LEADERSHIP
ON OFFENSE AND SO URGE I'VE-
THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU. THE
OPERATOR DID WE GET ALLEN BROOKS
YET. MOST ARE ANNOUNCING MISTER
BROOKS CONNECTED ON EITHER SIDE
OF THE LINE SIR OKAY. WILL MOVE
TO ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
EIGHT. ALL RIGHT SEE NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY EIGHT. THE
COMMON IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY TO
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YEAH MISTER CHAIR
WITHOUT PROPER IS KNOWN QUEUING
UP ALL RIGHT THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY EIGHT HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU APPLIED FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY EIGHT. UNTIL
COMMON OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. I GET MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO COMMENTERS IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THAN FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. RIGHT SEE
NONE MISTER GRAHAM A CLOSE. WELL
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IMPORTANT EFFORT- DR- TREES
ONE OF THE- FAMOUS AND
ACCOMPLISHED MERCED HINTS OF ALL
OF OUR HISTORY AND I THINK THIS
IS AN APPROPRIATE. RESPONSE TO
WORK LIFT UP MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY WHO HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATES AND CHAMPIONS AND
WARRIORS FOR JUSTICE AND CIVIL
RIGHTS AND WOULD APPRECIATE DR
VOTE- THIS MORNING THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE'LL TAKE A MOTION
ONCE WE GET A QUORUM. THANK YOU
MR THANK YOU. HI THIS FRIEDMAN
WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB TWENTY THREE OH NINE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
TWENTY HIT THREE OH NINE
STRENGTHENS EXISTING JUVENILE
COURT PROCEDURES TO OFFER
GUARDIANSHIP INSTEAD OF FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENT AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW I'VE DONE QUITE A BIT OF
WORK COULD TO SUPPORT OUR FOSTER
YOUTH SOME OF OUR MOST.
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF
THE EARLY STAGES OF A DEPENDENCY
COURT CASE IN THE DAY AND WEEKS
AFTER CHILD IS REMOVED FROM
THEIR CARE IS CRITICAL. THESE
HEARING COULD LEAVE EARLY COURT
HEARING TO DETERMINE WHERE A
CHILD WILL LIVE AND WHAT
SERVICES THE FAMILY WILL RECEIVE
FOR THE MONTHS AND SOMETIMES FOR
THE YEARS TO COME. IT'S ALSO AT
THIS EARLY STAGE THAT THE
DISPROPORTIONATE REPRESENTATION
OF FAMILIES OF COLOR IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IT MANIFESTS.
JUVENILE COURTS HAVE DISCRETION
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION THREE
SIXTY EIGHT TO ORDER A SAFE AND
PERMANENT GARTERS GUARDIANSHIP
AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENT. THIS OPTION TYPICALLY
ARISES UNDER SUCH A CERTAIN FACT
PATTERNS NAMELY ONE APPARENT
DECLINES OF FAMILY REUNIFICATION
SERVICES AFTER CONSULTATION WITH
THEIR ATTORNEY. AND IDENTIFIES A
FAMILY MEMBER OR OTHER KNOWN
ADULT TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
CHILD FOR THEM. CALIFORNIA
COURTS HAVE DESCRIBED THIS
OPTION IS ONE OF THE LAST
OPPORTUNITIES TO GIVE SOME
DEFENSE TO THE PARENTS OWN PLAN
FOR THEIR CHILD. AND TO KEEP
THAT CHILD IN CONNECTION WITH
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS AND
SOMETIMES THE FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENTS MAKE THAT VERY
DIFFICULT. BUT JUVENILE COURT
STAKEHOLDERS REPORT THAT
GUARDIANSHIP IN LIEU OF FOSTER
CARE. ARE NOT CONSIDERED EVEN
WHEN THAT OPTION WOULD BE IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD AND
THE FAMILY AT TIMES. COURTS ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO CONSIDER THE
PARENTS CHOICE OF A GUARDIAN AND
TYPICALLY DO NOT CONSIDER
GUARDIANSHIP UNTIL THE
DISPOSITIONAL HEARING AFTER THE
CHILD IS OFTEN BEEN PUT INTO
FOSTER CARE AND SPEND TIME.
THEIR FAMILY SOMETIMES FOR
MONTHS AB TWENTY THREE OH NINE
WOULD PROMOTE FAMILY DECISION
MAKING I MINIMIZE A CHILD'S
EXPOSURE TO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM WHEN THERE'S A SAFE AND
PERMANENT GUARDIAN AVAILABLE OF
COURSE THAT. WOULD HAVE. PER SE
. AND FOR. IS FOR TO THAT THE
CHILD'S. WELL BEING. THE BILL
UPDATES THE LAW BY ALLOWING THE
JUVENILE COURT ORDERED
GUARDIANSHIP EARLIER IN THE
DEPENDENT CORPORATE SAYS. AND
ALSO REQUIRES A JUVENILE COURT
TO SELECT THE PARENTS DESIGNATED
GUARDIAN. AS LONG AS THE CHILD
SAFETY IS NOT JEOPARDIZED AT
THIS POINT WHEN A PARENT
UNDERSTANDS THAT FOR WHATEVER
REASON THEY CAN'T PARENT THAT
CHILD. WE SHOULD BE LISTENING TO
THEIR VIEWS ABOUT WHAT'S BEST
FOR THEIR FAMILY AND FOR THAT
CHILD. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
DSS TO COLLECT DATA ON CHILDREN
LIVING WITH RELATIVE CAREGIVERS
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MOST
LIKELY TO BECOME GUARDIANS UNDER
THIS BILL. WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF AND WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE REFINE THE
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SO I DO HAVE ONE
WITNESS INDICATED SABRINA FORTE
THE ALLIANCE OF CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS WHO'S WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE. SEVEN FORTY ARE YOU
WITH US. YEAH I'M HERE GOOD
MORNING SHARON REMEMBERED PLAN
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS. THE
MORNING LINE FOR CHILDREN RIGHT
PHYSICALLY FIT BONTA AB TWENTY
THREE OH NINE AND BRIEF
BACKGROUND THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS THAT SPENT THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS COOKING FOCUS
GROUPS SURVEYS AND CONVENIENCE
ON THE EXPERIENCE THAT THE
PENSION CARE GIVERS BUILD
RELATIVE TO STEP UP TO CARE FOR
CHILDREN AFTER THOSE CHILDREN
ARE SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS
BY CHILD WELFARE. WE GATHER DATA
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SHOWING THAT ALTHOUGH THE CARE
GIVERS AND THE CHILDREN THEY
CARE FOR HAVE SIMILAR TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES AND COMPLEX NEEDS
FOR DECISIONS MADE EARLY IN THE
FAMILY'S INVOLVEMENT WITH CHILD
WELFARE CAN CREATE SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES. FAMILIES REPORTED A
RANGE OF EXPERIENCES AND WHETHER
THE PARENTS AND CHILDREN HAD
ACCESS TO ATTORNEYS WHETHER CARE
GIVERS RECEIVE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
SERVICES- CARING FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND WHETHER AT
RELATIVES AND PARENTS FELT THAT
THEY HAD A TANAMI AND
DETERMINING THE BEST ARRANGEMENT
FOR CHILDREN WITH HER MOBILE ALL
BUT NECESSARY. AB TWENTY THREE
OH NINE OUT OF THE AND IN A TEN
THAT I AND CHEN AND FIFTEEN BOOK
. FOR ONE AND OF THE CRITICAL
COME THE COURT THE THIRD IF
THERE'S ASPECT THE COUNT AND
RENTAL CAR ARE LACKING. WITH THE
LONG ALLOWS COURTS TO OR
GUARDIANS AND THAT. IS SUCH.
HERE PERRANCE CHILDREN ARE
PROVIDE COUNCIL BEFORE THE COURT
OR GUARDIAN AND FINANCIAL AND
SERVICES MAY BE AVAILABLE CAN
FANS AFTER THE COURT ORDERED BY
. BUT A LOT BE STRENGTHENED TO
ENSURE THAT FAMILIES AND
PARTICULARLY PARENTS PLAY MORE
OF A DECISION MAKING ROLE AND
THE FACT THAT AB TWENTY THREE OH
NINE DOES THAT BY GIVING THE
JUVENILE COURT FLEXIBILITY TO
ORDER GUARDIANSHIP PRIOR TO THE
DISPOSITION. AND REQUIRING THE
COURT TO CONSIDER THE PARENT
DESIGNATION A PARTY AND AS LONG
AS THERE ARE NO HELP.
MORE EQUITABLE FAMILY SUPPORT
THAT. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR CHAMPIONING THE
BELL AND I URGE THE COMMITTEE I
THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE OH
NINE. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WHICH
OPEN ALLIANCE FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY THREE OH NINE. BUT
CERTAINLY THE STRUCTURE. AND
JUST AS A AS AN UPDATE MISTER
BOOKS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO JOIN
YOUR CALL. TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE OH NINE PRESS STAR ZERO
PLEASE. HELLO FIRST JULY NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON
THE ON THE GO. HELLO THIS IS
JONATHAN GO CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB- TWENTY THREE OH NINE-
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THE SERVICE I WOULD
LOCK BENEFIT WHERE WE ARE ALL
CALLING TO THREE OH NINE THANK
YOU. WELL ALLIANCE. NINE WITH
SEVEN. ONCE GO PLEASE.
AGUIAR-CURRY MY MODER ON BEHALF
THAT IS CAL ACT INTO. MISTER
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
Q. THANK YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANY
ANY OPPOSITION LISTED BUT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE OH
NINE. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO'S LIKE SPEAKING OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE OH NINE. ONCE
AGAIN PROPOSITION FOR TWENTY
THREE ONLINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN ONE
NUMBER SIXTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
I ACTUALLY THIS ISN'T SUPPORT
JADI ON J. ACCORDING FOR AB
TWENTY THREE R. NINE FORMER
GUARDIAN. THAT'S WHY THANK YOU.
SURE WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
USING Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ARE
PRETTY MUCH CLOSE THE LINES WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NONE MS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY
CLOSE. I JUST- I ON BEHALF OF
THE FOSTER CHILDREN I WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE DO NOT YET HAVE
QUORUM SO WE'LL TAKE IT UP ONCE
WE DO. THANK YOU. LACK OF A
QUORUM LACK OF AUTHORS. RIGHT IT
LOOKS ROUGH MORNING. ALL RIGHTS
WILL WAIT.
SWILL MOVED OUT TO I DON'T
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING ME AND MISTER
BRYANT BECAUSE IT'S NO LONGER
QUORUM AT PUBLIC SAFETY SO. BUT
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX A BILL THAT WOULD
AFFORD THE CALIFORNIA
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO CONTINUE IT'S
IMPORTANT WORK AND TWENTY TWENTY
THIS LEGISLATURE. APPROVED AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE WHICH MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST STATE IN
THE NATION TO ESTABLISH A ASK
FORCE TO STUDY THE INSTITUTION
OF FORCE CHATTEL SLAVERY AND
REMUNERATION FOR THE STATE'S
COMPLICITY IN THAT SYSTEM. THAT
LAW DIRECTED THE TASK FORCE
TOGETHER AND SYMPATHIZE
DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE OF SLAVERY
IN ITS ONGOING LEGACY DEVELOP
WAYS TO EDUCATE CALIFORNIANS
ABOUT ITS FINDINGS AND RECOMMEND
APPROPRIATE REMEDIES IN A REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE THIS
MONUMENTAL CHARGES NOT. TAKEN
LIGHTLY. I WITH THE HELP OF THE
INCREDIBLE TEAM IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DIVISIONS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE TASK
FORCE IS WORKING TO ENSURE THAT
WE GATHER AS MUCH OF IT
EVIDENCES COMMITTEE POSSIBLE AND
PRODUCE A REPORT THAT CAN BE
USED AS A STARTING POINT FOR
OTHER STATES AND ULTIMATELY THE
NATION. TO THAT END THE TASK FOR
IS HUMBLED BY THE COUNTLESS
HOURS OF TESTIMONY AND THOUSANDS
OF PAGES OF DOCUMENTS FROM
AGENCIES HISTORIANS PARK PRIVATE
ECONOMISTS BUSINESSES LEGAL
EXPERTS FAMILIES A FORMER SLAVE
OWNERS AND THE DESCENDANTS OF
SLAVES AND SHARECROPPERS DOES
WORK TAKES TIME AND EVEN. AFTER
THE PRELIMINARY REPORT IS
PUBLISHED THERE WILL BE
UNDOUBTEDLY BE WORK TO BE DONE
BEYOND THE CURRENT JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SUNSET DATE.
THE SLAVES WHO BUILT THIS
COUNTRY THEIR DESCENDANTS AND
ALL THOSE IMPACTED BY THE WHIPS
AND CHAINS OF HUMAN SUBJUGATION
DESERVE A COMPLETE AND THOROUGH
EXAMINATION TO SYSTEM THAT IN
TRACTORS AT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. SHIRLEY WEBER OFTEN
STATES FORTY YEARS OF OPPRESSION
WILL NOT BE SOLVED IN FOUR
HUNDRED DAYS. AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX WILL PROVIDE ATTACHED
WITH WITH EXPANDED TIMELINE SO
IT IS ABLE TO CONTINUE EXECUTING
HIS BASCO PUT DUTIES AND DEVELOP
BALK VOTE RECOMMENDATIONS WITH
THE CAREFUL CONSIDERATION THEY
DESERVE. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MEMBERS SPECTER IAGO
. THANK YOU WE WILL HOUSING
ESTATE CORE. STONE HERE
CUNNINGHAM DAVIES. HOLD KALRA.
KILEY MAIN SHOW. FOR RIVAS THERE
. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE QUORUM SO
THANK THERE IS A MOTION AND A
AND THE SECOND THANK YOU. RIGHT
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX. I WOULD ELEMENT
TO OPT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX PRESS ONE
ZERO POINTS I WILL GO TO LIVE A
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THIRTY FOUR JENNIFER
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
JENNIFER BACKSTROKE FRIENDSHIP
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE THAT CARE
GIVERS AND I WAS IN Q. FOUR
EIGHT THE TWENTY THREE OH NINE
AND I RESPECTFULLY. I THINK YOU
WOULD EXPECT HOURS. FOR AN
EIGHTY TWENTY THREE ON NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THAT MOVING
ON WHILE LINE TO TWO ONE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GOING. GOOD MORNING-
MY NAME IS CLAUDIA. CALLING
BEHALF OF COMMUNITY HEALTH COUNT
IN THE ANGELES CA IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX THANK
YOU. MISTER CALDERON LOW PUBLIC
COMMENTERS IN KINSTON. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WHICH OPEN
ALLIANCE FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX. TO
SPEAK UP A LIST OF TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. MISTER CALDERON LOW COMMENTERS
ACUTE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES THAT I WILL
BRING IT BACK. TO THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS JUST FOR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY VERY VERY IMPORTANT
WORK. AND IF THEY NEED A BIT
MORE TIME SPECIALLY IT'S- KIND
OF EXCITING TO SEE ALL OF THE
RESPONSE IN THE VOLUMINOUS.
INFORMATION THAT THEY GET TO
WORK WITH AND THAT I THINK THAT
IS. FAIR AND APPROPRIATE FOLKS
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN DESCENT I
HAVE SUFFERED A LONG TIME IN A
LITTLE BIT LONGER TO GET IT
RIGHT. IS VERY APPROPRIATE. SO
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
RIGHT SIGNAL YOU MAY CLOSE ERIC
SPEKTR ASKRI I WROTE THANK YOU
AND THEN YOU CAN GET BACK TO
YOUR- COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL STONE AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM DAVIES. HOLDEN
KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES REYES I
RIVAS RIVAS STE THAT NEEDS TO
MORE SO THE BILL'S ON CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER BRYANT. AND
THEN MOVED TO I'VE NEVER SIX AB. TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE. WHAT
GOOD MORNING THIS COULD BE BACK
WITH YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- HERE TO PRESENT A TWO
ONE FIFTEEN A BILL WOULD STOP
PERMANENT FAMILY SEPARATION THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. FOR
PARENTS WERE PRE TRIAL MEANING
THEY'RE NOT THEY'VE NOT BEEN
CONVICTED OF ANY WRONGDOING. I
WANNA CHAU PROTECTIVE SERVICE
CASES OPEN IN A CHILD IS PLACED
IN FOSTER CARE CBS IS REQUIRED
TO ASSESS ELIGIBILITY FOR ALL
PARENTS FOR REUNIFICATION
SERVICES. THEY'RE ALSO REQUIRED
TO BEGIN ASSISTING THAT PARENT
WITH THE PROCESS OF REUNITING
WITH THEIR CHILD. FOR PARENTS IN
CUSTODY THIS COULD INCLUDE AN
INVESTIGATING WHAT SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE AT THE PLACE WHERE
SOMEBODY'S INCARCERATED A
SERVICES IN A SERVICES ANGER
MANAGEMENT. LIFE SKILLS. IN
ADDITION A FORM TO SUPPORT.
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF FILING A
CHILD WELFARE CASE TO JUVENILE
DEPENDENCY COURT MUST DECIDE
WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO ORDER
THE PARENT AND TO BE INFORMATION
SERVICES. OR IF THEY SHOULD BE
BYPASS FOR THE SERVICES. BECAUSE
THEY FIT INTO ONE OF THE
CRITERIA BEING DENIED FOR
REUNIFICATION. IF BOTH PARENTS
ARE BY PASSED THE COURT WILL SET
A HEARING MAKE A PERMIT PLAN FOR
THE CHILD WHICH COULD LEAD TO
THE TERMINATION. OF PARENTAL
RIGHTS FOREVER. IN CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE SEVENTEEN DIFFERENT BY
PRESS PROVISIONS CURRENTLY. THE
PROBLEM THIS BILL WILL FIX. IS
IN A SEPARATION PROVISION THAT
CURRENTLY STATES THAT IF YOU ARE
A PARENT. WHO IS INCARCERATED
AND NOT CONVICTED OF A CRIME IN
YOUR SIMPLY PRE TRIAL AND YOU
COULD NOT HAVE AFFORDED YOUR
BAIL. YOU CAN STILL BE BYPASS
FOR FAMILY REUNIFICATION
SERVICES. WE HAVE TO FIX THIS
THE DO POST BAIL. AND ARE GOING
TO THE SAME UNIFICATION PROCESS
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE
POSSIBILITY OF BEING DENIED
THEIR REUNIFICATION SERVICES.
FOR YEARS WE HAVE FUMBLED THE
BALL IN THE STATE LEGISLATOR ON
PRE TRIAL REFORM BUT IN THE
MEANTIME THERE ARE COUNTLESS
CHILDREN WHO ARE FALLING THROUGH
THE CRACKS. ADDING ADDITIONAL
STRAIN TOWARD TRAVEL FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BEING DENIED
REUNIFICATION SERVICES WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND WE KNOW THE
BLACK BROWN POINT INDIGENOUS
FAMILIES ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY ALL OF THE ABOVE. AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE WILL
ENSURE THAT PARENTS WERE PRE
TRIAL WILL NOT BE DENIED FAMILY
REUNIFICATION SERVICES SOLELY
BECAUSE THEY ARE TOO POOR TO
POST A BAIL. PARENTS WERE
CONVICTED OF WRONGDOING BY THE
WAY ARE STILL BY PASSED FOR
THOSE REUNIFICATION SERVICES TO
THE SIMPLY APPLIES TO PARENTS
WHO ARE PRE TRIAL. TO GIVE
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M JOINED BY
JULIA HANNIGAN AN ATTORNEY WITH
THE DEBATE THE PENDENCY LEGAL
SERVICES AND CHRISTINA CURTIS
WHO IS AN ATTORNEY WITH THE LOS
ANGELES DEPENDENCY LAWYERS.
THANK YOU MISTER BRYANT I DO
HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES
INDICATED BOTH WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE JULIA HANNIGAN. ARE
YOU WITH US. YES THANK YOU OUR
FIRST I WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED MEMBERS ALL
THE TIME OR GET. MY NAME IS
JULIE HENEGHAN AND I AM A POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR DEPENDENCY LEGAL
SERVICES. WHEN I WAS PREPARING
TO ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE I
SPOKE TO ONE OF OUR CONTRACT
ATTORNEYS. WHO TOLD ME ABOUT HIS
CLIENT WELCOME NUMBER. TWO
MONTHS AGO AND I THOUGHT SHE WAS
GOING ON A DATE WITH HER
BOYFRIEND SHE KNEW THIS MAN AS
HE IS THE FATHER OF HER TWO
YOUNG CHILDREN. BUT SHE DID NOT
KNOW THAT ON THIS PARTICULAR DAY
HER BOYFRIEND WAS GOING TO
COMMIT. A SERIOUS FELONY. GIVEN
THAT AMBER WAS IN THE CAR SHE
TOO HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
FIFTEEN FELONIES. THE CRIMINAL
COURT COURT IS HOLDING HER
WITHOUT BAIL CPS REMOVED HER TWO
CHILDREN. AS WE SIT HERE TODAY
AMBER IS INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN
GUILTY OF CRIMINAL CHARGES ARE
PENDING AND MAY NOT BE RESOLVED
FOR MONTHS. AMBER IS ALSO A
PERSON OF COLOR AS ARE MANY OF
THE CLIENTS MISTER. IN TWO DAYS
FROM TODAY A JUVENILE DEPENDENCY
JUDGE IS GOING TO TELL AMBER
THAT SHE WILL NEVER BE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET HER CHILDREN
BACK. CURRENT LAW PROVIDES AT
CBS AND THE COURT HAS THE
ABILITY TO MAKE THIS DECISION.
AND DOES SO WITH GREAT FREQUENCY
. THIS BILL HOWEVER WILL ENSURE
THAT COURTS CANNOT DENY FAMILIES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REUNIFY WITH
THEIR CHILDREN. UNTIL OR UNLESS
THE PARENT IS CONVICTED OF THE
CRIME FOR WHICH THEY ARE
INCARCERATED. REMEMBER THIS BILL
WILL BE TOO LATE. AFTER THURSDAY
THE COURT WITH A HEARING IN JULY
TO TURN. TO TERMINATE HER
PARENTAL RIGHTS. IF CHARGES ARE
DROPPED OR NEGOTIATED AN AMBER
IS RELEASED BEFORE THEN SHE WILL
STILL HAVE TO PROVE WHY IT IS IN
HER CHILDREN'S BEST INTERESTS
SHOULD BE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO YOU KNOW. AND IT'S LIKELY OUR
COURTS. EVEN GIVE HER HEARING
BEFORE THANK. IF THE CHARGES ARE
DROPPED OR SHE IS RELEASED IN
AUGUST OR AFTERWARDS HER
CHILDREN WILL ALREADY HAVE BEEN
FREE FOR ADOPTION AND SHE WILL
HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO LEGAL
RECOURSE. OUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SUPREME COURT ONE THROAT THERE
IS NO GO TO JAIL THAT YOUR KIDS
WILL IN CALIFORNIA. FOLLOWING
MANY WAYS OUR SYSTEM DOES NOT
LIVE UP TO THIS PROVINCE AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE WILL GO A
LONG WAY TOWARD GIVING FAMILIES
A TO TAKE.
ADVANTAGE OF SERVICES DESIGNED
TO HELP THEM IT WILL ALLOW
PARENTS IN CUSTODY PRIOR TO
TRIAL HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
HAS THOSE WHO ARE OUT ON BAIL.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEMPT TO
FIX THE PROBLEMS THAT REUNITE
WITH THEIR CHILDREN. WE ASK FOR
YOUR HELP. THANK YOU. THEN
CRISTINA CURTIS. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
CURTIS AND I AM A SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY WITH THE LAW OFFICE OF
THE TENNESSEE LAWYERS AND THE
COACH OUR CULTURE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE FOR BOTH LOS ANGELES
THE PENALTY LAWYER IN SAN DIEGO
LEGAL SERVICES. LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAS THE BIGGEST CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM IN THE UNITED
STATES SO IN PREPARATION FOR MY
TESTIMONY TODAY. I WAS CONFIDENT
I'D BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
PERFECT WITNESS TO GIVE THAT
SYMPATHETIC STORY TO SHARE WITH
YOU. HOWEVER I DO NOT HAVE ONE.
NOT BECAUSE IT SHOULD NOT A
PROBLEM THE ONE. THE BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM IS SO PREVALENT. MOST OF
OUR ATTORNEYS HAVE REPRESENTED
AN INCARCERATED PARENT AWAITING
TRIAL WHO HAD BEEN BY PASSED BY
THIS PROVISION HOWEVER BY THE
TIME A CLIENT IN THE QUITTED FOR
THE CRIMES THEY WERE CHARGED
WITH THE DAMAGE AS LONG BEEN
DONE. IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
HERE HOW THE TIMELINE TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE ONE
APPARENTLY BY PASSED. COMPARED
TO THE TIMELINE TO CONCLUDE A
CRIMINAL CASE. WHERE THE
CRIMINAL CASE CAN AT TIMES TAKE
OVER A YEAR TO PROSECUTE. WHEN A
PARENT OF BY PASSED POINT A
RIGHT TO BE TERMINATED AND THE
CHILD FREED FOR ADOPTION AND IS
LITTLE IN SIX MONTHS FROM
INITIATION. OF THE DEPENDENCY
CASE. THIS MEANS THAT BY THE
TIME A PARENT BEEN ACQUITTED FOR
THE CRIME CHARGED THEIR CHILD IS
LIKELY COMPLETED FOR ADOPTION
AND OUR TIME FOR APPEAL HAS LONG
PASSED. THIS LAW AS IT CURRENTLY%
STANDS ALSO HAS AN EVEN WIDER
IMPLICATIONS THAN JUST AFFECTING
APPEARANCE RIGHT TO PARENT THEIR
CHILDREN. IT CAN BE USED AS A
BARGAINING CHIP TO ENCOURAGE A
PERSON IN CUSTODY. ENTER A PLEA
IN A CRIMINAL CASE RATHER THAN
GO TO TRIAL TO DEFEND THEIR
INTENT. AFTER ALL A PERSON MAY
BE WILLING TO SACRIFICE TIME IN
JAIL TO PROVE THEIR INNOCENCE.
BUT IF IT MEANS THAT THEY COULD
PROBABLY LOSE CUSTODY OF THEIR
CHILDREN. DOING WHATEVER IS
NECESSARY TO GET OUT OF JAIL
SINCE MUCH MORE IMPORTANT. AMONG
OTHER THINGS CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS AFFECT A PERSON'S
ABILITY TO OBTAIN EMPLOYMENT.
AND SOME CONVICTIONS PREVENT
PERSONS FROM BEING ABLE TO SELL.
TO BE CLEAR. PROP BY AND LARGE.
PARENTS YOU CAN AFFORD BAIL. THE
GREAT MANS WHO COULD AFFORD
BILL WILL ABSOLUTELY BE GIVEN A
CHANCE TO GET THEIR CHILDREN
BACK IN THE CARE TO
REUNIFICATION START. BUT
APPARENTLY CANNOT. RISK HAVING
THEIR CHILDREN PLAY PRODUCTION
AND LIGHTING. ALTHOUGH THE LAW
WAS CREATED WITHOUT THE CONTENT
AFTER THE FINANCE WELFARE
INSTITUTION'S CODE THREE SIXTY
ONE POINT FIVE HE CONTINUES TO
MARGINALIZE ALREADY MARGINALIZED
FAMILIES BUT PERMANENTLY
REMOVING CHILDREN FROM THEIR
CARE. THIS IS WHY AB TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE IT'S
SO IMPORTANT. IT IS THE FIRST
STEP. FORWARD SOLVENT FAIR
TREATMENT A FAMILY THE CHILD
WELFARE. I WOULD URGE YOU TO
VOTE HI AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY
ONE FIFTY NINE. SEEING NONE ARE
PRETTY WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
ONE FIFTY NINE. WE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE TAKING FURTHER TESTIMONY
BUT WILL TAKE NAME AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE NUMBER SEVEN FEET
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
ONE MOMENT THE STRUCTURE WILL GO
TO THE OTHER OF THE OTHER
COMMENTERS. AND THAT'S WHAT OF
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN LINE
THIRTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. IN
THE WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE
THANK YOU. UNLESS WE HAVE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOINT AQUATIC CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTERS IN Q.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
ONE FIFTY NINE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY ONE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. SURE WE HAVE NO
COMMENT JUST GIVING UP THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ARE PRETTY
MAY CLOSE ALLIANCE OFFERING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT MS REYES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT'S SOMETIMES WE SEE
THESE INJUSTICES AND WE THINK
THAT- THEY DON'T REALLY HAPPEN
THAT SOMEBODY WILL TAKE CARE OF
IT AND THEY DON'T TAKE CARE OF
IT SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING US
AND WITH THAT I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT. SO
OFTEN WE TRY TO ROOT OUT
INJUSTICE IN THE SYSTEM ITSELF
AND IN THE WAY THAT. CASES
BROUGH MOVE FORWARD AND- X.
SHOULD BE SURPRISED A CONSTANTLY
COMING UP AGAIN WITH ISSUES THAT
ARE. VERY DRAMATIC AND HUGELY
IMPACTFUL ON COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND THE POOR AND JUST
SHOWS THAT THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
NOT WORKING IN THEIR FAVOR SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD KEEPING FAMILIES
TOGETHER IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS WE CAN DO. AND
GIVING THEM THE SUPPORTS TO BE
STRONG FAMILIES THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT SO I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS FORWARD ARE
MISTER BRIAN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW I'M ONE OF NINE
ADOPTED CHILDREN IN THE FAMILY
THAT DID FOSTER CARE FOR TWENTY
SIX YEARS AND OVER. HUNDRED
FIFTY FOSTER SIBLINGS I'VE SEEN
THE RIGHTS TERMINATED IN THE
IDEA THAT YOU CAN LOSE CUSTODY
OF YOUR CHILDREN FOREVER BECAUSE
YOU WERE TOO POOR TO POST BAIL
EVEN FOR CHARGES FOR WHICH YOU
WERE EVENTUALLY ACQUITTED OR HAD
DROPPED IS UNCONSCIONABLE
ESPECIALLY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I'M PROUD TO HAVE
AUTHORED THIS BILL IN A REQUEST
FOR THE ACTUAL ADULT. THANK YOU
MISTER BRYANT SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND THAT MOTION IS
TO PASS TO HUMAN SERVICES CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE HI STONE
I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
DAVIES. HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE REYES REYES AYE RIVAS. RIVAS
I. THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT MISTER GIBSON I THINK
I SOME COME S. HE WAS HIDING BUT
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR MISTER
GIBSON WELFARE THANK YOU. FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR WHICH
SEEKS TO ALLOW CHILDREN. AND
YOUNG ADULTS A CHANCE TO SAFELY
UNDERSCORE SAFELY CONNECT WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD DO
A FEW THINGS. ENSURE POST
ADOPTION CONTRACTS TO CONTINUE
VISITATIONS BETWEEN SIBLINGS.
ARE SIBLINGS ARE ADDRESSED-
PRIOR TO TERMINATION OF PARENTAL
RIGHTS. ENSURE SIBLINGS
VISITATIONS CONTINUES PAST THE
END OF PARENTAL RIGHTS. CLARIFY
THE ADULTS SIBLINGS EVEN IF
PREVIOUSLY ADOPTED OUR VIEW AS
SIBLINGS UNDER THE LAW REQUIRES
THAT THE OLDER SIBLINGS IN
FOSTER CARE BE GIVEN NOTICE OF
ANY PLANS OF ADOPTION OF THEIR
YOUNGER SIBLINGS AND ALLOW
PARENTAL RIGHTS TO BE REINSTATED
FOR NON MINERS IN FOSTER CARE
AFTER ADOPTION. HAS FAILED.
THROUGH THE COBIT NINETEEN
CRISIS CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS
CONTINUE TO STAY BECAUSE TO
STATES THAT SAY. THEY WANT TO BE
CONNECTED TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
EXPRESSLY SIBLINGS WHO NEEDS
THEIR OTHER SIBLINGS FOR SUPPORT
. BEING A FATHER AND A BROTHER
IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE BEING
WITHOUT THE BOND. DOING WHAT WE
CAN WHEN WE CAN IS THE START OF
A BETTER FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IN
THIS STATE. NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
TIMES A DAY A CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA IS PLACED IN FOSTER
CARE. JUST IMAGINE THAT THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALONE HAS OVER
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND. FOSTER
YOUTH AND IT MAKES SENSE FOR
CHILDREN WHO WANT TO LIVE WITH
THEIR BIRTH PARENTS TO HAVE AN
OPTION TO KEEP FAMILIES
CONNECTED. IN SOME CASES THE
ADOPTION FAILS AND THE CHILDREN
HAS TO RE ESTABLISH RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEIR PARENTS. HOWEVER THE
STRUCTURE THE STRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT THIS PROCESS IS LACKING
. OLDER FOSTER YOUTH NEED HELP
WHEN FOSTER YOU TERMINATES TERM
TERMS OUT OF THE SYSTEM THEY ARE
LEFT WITHOUT RESOURCES. HAVING
FAMILY CONNECTION DURING THIS
TIME TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AS A
MEMBER OF THE SELECT CMMITTEE
ON NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS I AM
ALSO AWARE OF THE CRISIS WITH
THE NATIVE AMERICAN FOSTER YOUTH
THE CRISIS IS SIMILAR TO THOSE
IN THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND THE LATINO
COMMUNITY. FAMILY CULTURE
CONNECTION MATTERS. AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY FOUR STRENGTHEN FAMILIES
CONNECTION. EVERY CHILD DESERVES
. LOVE AND A PERMANENT
RELATIONSHIP EVERY CHILD
DESERVES TO FEEL SAFE. ONCE IT
LOVED AND HEARD BY THE
COMMUNITIES THEY IDENTIFY AND
FOSTER COMMUNITY AND FOSTER
COMMUNITY CONNECTIONS AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR MEMBERS
PROVIDE A PATH FORWARD FOR THESE
FAMILIES. JOINING ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. IS
MEREDITH ALEXANDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LAWCENTER AN OLD LET
ME ALSO PAUSE TO SAY WE ALSO
QUEUED UP TO YOU TO BE WITH US
BUT THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN COURT FOR THE
SAME REASON FIGHTING. FOR THE
RIGHTS. THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON
SO I DO HAVE ONE WITNESS LISTED
MEREDITH ALEXANDER OF THE
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE. ALEXANDER ARE YOU
WITH US. YES I'M HERE GO AHEAD
PLEASE AT FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOU FIRST I WANT TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON FOR
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION WHICH WILL
STRENGTHEN FAMILY CONNECTIONS
AND ULTIMATELY FOSTER BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH INVOLVED IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM I'M
MEREDITH ALEXANDER AN ATTORNEY
SUPERVISOR AT THE CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA. I WAS
PREVIOUSLY A CATERING ATTORNEY
FOR CLC REPRESENTING CHILDREN IN
DEPENDENCY COURT DALY AND BEFORE
JOINING CLC I WORKED IN FAMILY
LAW. DOT THE LARGEST CHILDREN'S
LEGAL SERVICES ORGANIZATION IN
THE NATION ADVOCATING FOR OVER
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE. IN LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO. AND PLASTER
COUNTY EACH YEAR. IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM IF A CHILD CANNOT
SAFELY BE REUNIFIED WITH THEIR
FAMILY ADOPTION IS THE PREFERRED
PLAN. PERMANENT IS CRITICAL FOR
OUR CLIENTS BUT THERE'S ALSO A
GROWING RECOGNITION THAT FOR
MANY ADOPTEES IT IS ALSO
CRITICAL TO MAINTAIN SOME
CONNECTION TO THEIR BIOLOGICAL
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY. AND THAT
MAINTAINING THESE CONNECTIONS
CAN OFTEN BE SPACE AND PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT. I'VE SEEN
IN NUMEROUS CASES THAT WHILE
ADOPTION CAN BRING GREAT JOY
THERE CAN ALSO BE A SIGNIFICANT
GRIEF AND LOSS WHEN A CHILD IS
PERMANENTLY CUT FROM ALL
CONNECTION TO THEIR FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY. RESEARCH ESEARCH
SHOWS THE SIBLING BOND IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN
MITIGATING THE TRAUMA OF FAMILY
SEPARATION. FEEDBACK WE HEAR
FROM OUR CLIENTS HAS REINFORCED
THE VERACITY OF THIS RESEARCH.
WELL THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAINTAINING SIBLING CONNECTIONS
POST ADOPTION IS ALREADY
RECOGNIZED IN THE LAW BY
REQUIRING CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES
TO SET UP A MEETING TO EXECUTE
OPPOSED ADOPTION CONTRACT WHEN
PRACTICABLE. IN PRACTICE WE
RARELY SEE THESE MEETINGS TAKE
PLACE AND TOO OFTEN WE SEE OUR
CLIENTS WITH ALL CONTACT WITH
THEIR SIBLINGS RESULTING IN
TRAUMA THAT CAN LAST WELL INTO
ADULTHOOD. THIS BILL WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE EXISTING LAW TO
ENSURE THESE MEETINGS TO TAKE
PLACE TO DISCUSS THE POSSIBILITY
OF POSTED OPTION CONTACT BETWEEN
SIBLINGS. ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
WILL CREATE PATHWAYS TO
REINSTATE PARENTAL RIGHTS FOR
USE WHEN IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
AND IN THEIR BEST INTEREST. I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND AGAIN
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AND STRENGTHENING
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT TO AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HOPE SOMEONE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
INFORMATION. WE'LL START WITH
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX POINT
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS MOLLY SHANNON WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'M ACTUALLY
AT LINE TWENTY FOUR GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THIS IS JOHN DIDN'T GO
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKES CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT USING KEEP. THANK YOU I
DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
LISTED WHAT IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR. SEEING
NONE OPERATORS YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR. YOU
MISTER CHAIR TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SEVENTEEN NINETY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. SURE
WE HAVE NO COMMENT THIS YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LINES- BRING IT. BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AS THEIR SECOND. AND A
SECOND THANK YOU THIS GIPSON
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AS I WAS FIRST OF
ALL I WISH THE TWO WHO WERE
GOING TO BE SCARED TO BE HERE
THE VERY VERY BEST IN COURT
TODAY. I'M REMINDED OF A YOUNG
MAN WHO- WAS SEPARATED- IN THE
SAN GABRIEL AREA- HE HIS BROTHER
HIS BIOLOGICAL BROTHER- AND HIS
CELL THE SIBLINGS WERE SEPARATED
BUT AS BIOLOGICAL BROTHER LIVE
FIVE BLOCKS FROM WHERE HE LIVED
. AND THE SOCIAL WORKER WAS
GOING TO CONNECT THEM. THIS WAS
THREE YEARS AGO. AND THE DAY
BEFORE. THEY WERE GOING TO BE
CONNECTED. HIS BROTHER WAS
KILLED. AND THEY NEVER GOT A
CHANCE TO CREATE A BOND THEY
NEVER GOT A CHANCE TO- TO SEE
WHETHER NOT EACH OTHER HAVE THE
SAME COLOR HAT MANNERISMS OF
THEIR PARENTAL- PARENTS. THIS IS
A COMMON SENSE BILL SEVENTEEN
NINETY FOUR THAT STRENGTH IS A
PROCESS. THAT WOULD PUBLIC
FAMILY CONNECTIONS FOR DOBSON'S
AND WENT UP WHEN APPROPRIATE
THIS BILL SUPPORT- CONTACT
BETWEEN SIBLINGS AND SAFE AND IN
A SAFE WAY AND ALLOW A BETTER
PATH FOR PARENTAL RIGHTS. TO BE
REINSTATED FOR CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND ADOPTION LET ME
SIMPLY SAY THIS OF A CLOSE I
NEVER BEEN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. NEVER BEEN ADOPTED BUT
MY HEART GOES OUT AND IT'S THIS
IS MY OPPORTUNITY TO STAND UP
BUT THOSE WHO CANNOT STAND UP
FOR THEMSELVES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND THAT MOTIONS TO PASS TO
HUMAN SERVICES KALRA PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE. CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES.AB I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I KALRA. KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN PARK MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES REYES HI RIVAS. RIVAS
THANK YOU THE BILLS OUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. EXIST TO
OUR ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT MISTER
CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. YOUR PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT TODAY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS WE ALL KNOW
IS THE WORLD'S FASTEST GROWING
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE IT'S
ESTIMATED TO BE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR A YEAR
INDUSTRY ADDITIONALLY HOTELS AND
MOTELS WERE THE THIRD MOST
COMMON VENUE FOR SEX TRAFFICKING
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND HAVE
ROUTINELY BEEN IN THE TOP THREE
VENUES SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN. A
RECENT STUDY BY THE POLARIS
PROJECT FOUND THAT 75% OF
SURVIVORS REPORTED COMING INTO
CONTACT WITH HOTELS OR MOTELS AT
SOME POINT DURING THEIR
TRAFFICKING SITUATION. WHAT
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD DO
IS ALLOW FOR THE FIRST TIME.
CITY ATTORNEYS AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS TO BRING CIVIL ACTIONS
AGAINST HOTELS AND MOTELS. ONLY
IN CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
SUPERVISING EMPLOYEE NEW OR
ACTED WITH WITH RECKLESS
DISREGARD. TO SEX TRAFFICKING
HAPPENING ON THE PREMISES. THE
BILL CREATES A SAFE HARBOR FROM
LIABILITY IF ANY EMPLOYEE
REPORTS THE ACTIVITY TO EITHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT THE NATIONAL
TRAFFICKING HOTLINE OR ANOTHER
APPROPRIATE VICTIM SERVICES
CENTER. THIS ILL BUILDS ON THE
WORK THIS LEGISLATURE IN THIS
COMMITTEE HAS DONE BACK IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE PASSED SB
NINE SEVENTY- SENATOR ATKINS THE
REQUIRES HOSPITALITY EMPLOYEES
TO RECEIVE TRAFFICKING TRAINING
TO HELP IDENTIFY THE SIGNS OF
TRAFFICKING I THINK THIS IS A
LOGICAL NEXT STEP TO CREATE
INCENTIVE TO ACTUALLY HAVE THIS
ACTIVITY REPORTED TO. THE
AUTHORITIES TO THE HOTLINE OR TO
VICTIM SERVICES CENTER.
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT UNDER
FEDERAL LAW THE FEDERAL
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS PROTECTION
ACT. ALLOWS FEDERAL PROSECUTORS.
OR VICTIMS TO BRING CIVIL OR
CRIMINAL ACTIONS AGAINST HOTELS
BUT IT HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY
UNDER UTILIZED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WE SEE. AS YOU MIGHT
EXPECT THE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
BEING BROUGHT AGAINST
INTERNATIONAL CARTELS AND SO
FORTH- BUT THERE'S NO REMEDY FOR
A LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR
CITY ATTORNEY. WHO'S MORE LIKELY
TO KNOW THAT THE ACTIVITIES
GOING ON IN THE COMMUNITY AND
HAS THE RESOURCES TO ADDRESS IT
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- BY ALLOWING
THIS WILL CLOSE THE GAP AND
GIVE. LOCAL ATTORNEYS ANOTHER
TOOL TO COMBAT TRAFFICKING IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. HERE WITH ME
TODAY IS CAN STONE WITH CDA TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
DO HAVE THE ONE WITNESS LISTED.
GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING KIM STONE
OF STONE ADVOCACY REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. AS YOU
ALL KNOW HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CONTINUES IT'S A GROWING PROBLEM
IT'S A VICIOUS PROBLEM AND IT
DESERVES CREATIVE SOLUTIONS.
LIKE THIS BILL OFFERS. THE CIVIL
PENALTIES THAT WOULD BE AFFORDED
IS AN ADDITIONAL TOOL FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO PROSECUTE.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES WILL
INCENTIVIZE HOTEL SUPERVISORY
EMPLOYEES TO REPORT- IF THEY
BELIEVE OR SUSPECT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS HAPPENING AT THAT
PROCESS. AND THE AMENDMENTS WILL
PROVIDE PROTECTION TO WELL
INTENTIONED AND TELL EMPLOYEES
FOR DOING THE RIGHT THING. THAT
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORTS THE BILL AND URGES YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND SPEAKING
OF AMENDMENTS ARE AMENDMENTS
YOU'RE TAKING THOSE AUTHORS OF
ADMITS YES THANK YOU YEAH THANK
YOU. RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. ALL
RIGHT SEE NINE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I STRUCTURE WE HAVE NOBODY
IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT I THANK YOU
I DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
LISTED BUT IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVENTY EIGHTY EIGHT. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
ALLIANCE FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO A
B. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. YOU
CAN OPPOSITION FOR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE LITTLE LINE NUMBER SEVENTEEN
GO AHEAD PLEASE- IT HAS THE
BACKUP CAMERA IN THE HOUSE ACLU
CALIFORNIA I'D HOPE TO BE THERE
IN PERSON TO DID NOT WIND UP AS
A WITNESS AT BUT WITH BE ALRIGHT
I TAKE A TWO MINUTE THAT HAVE TO
NOT THE- YES PLEASE GO. THANK
YOU SACRAMENTO ON THE- OF A
VALUE. ACTION AND THUS FAR. OP
UNLESS THAT IS BETTER MANDATE.
WE THE AUTHOR'S DESIRE TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AN AMENDMENT.
SEEKING TODAY. HOWEVER WE REMAIN
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION UNLESS
THE BILL AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
REPORTING ONLY SELECTIVE
SERVICES. AND OTHER COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
BEST EQUIPPED. TO RESPOND TO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. ANTI
TRAFFICKING ORGAN TAT AS THE
CALL TOOK THE ANTI. I'VE CALLED
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACHES TO
RESPOND HUMAN TRAFFICKING. WELL
THE BILL ALLOWS CALLING CUTS
ORGANIZATION AND LONGER THAN
FARMING MON FORCE MEANT AS
LISTED AS ONE OF THE OPTIONS. TO
ESCAPE LIABILITY RESTS ABOUT
WILL SEEM LIKE THE EASIEST COLOR
TO MAKE PROFOUND HOTEL. AND AT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
THERE ARE MET TO MONEY RIGHT. TO
NOTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT RATHER
THAN ORGANIZATIONS. CHANGE
RESPONSE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INCLUDING FAILING TO CONNECT
TOPIC IN VICTIMS NEEDED
RESOURCES POTENTIALLY
TRAUMATIZING VICTIMS AND RAISING
FEARS THE COURT FOR IMMIGRANTS.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE
HUSBAND HIGH CON. FOR PEOPLE BY
NOT EXTRACT BAKED. BY MAKING HER
HELP ENHANCE THE LIABLE THE BILL
. OVERLAP I HOTEL BY SEVERAL
PANEL. YET MANY OF THAT THAT'S
AND THE PAYMENT. IDENTIFY BY THE
PROJECT COULD INDEED ABOUT AWAY
THAT YOU. HAVING FEW PERSON TO
THAT OR SHOW I OF OR- OF THE I
INDICATE THAT AT THE KEEPING A
THE MARKET. SITUATION NOT BEING
. ABOUT ONE NAME OR ADDRESS OR
CHECKING AND YOU KNOW A- COULD
INDICATE THAT MAY ON A-
IMMIGRANTS. WORRIED ABOUT THE-
OR A PERSON NOT MONEY TO BE
CAUGHT HAVING A MERIT AFFAIR.
RENTING EVERY IF YOU WERE
CONTAGION COULD AND GET A PER
SPENDING THAT THE- WHILE COULD
PUT THE- ATTY AND PROVIDE.
CLOTHING AND BITES OF PROFILING
OF WOMEN BODIES PORTRAY. VICTIM
SERVICE ARE. I FASTER TO. L. ARE
PART. ACTUALLY REQUIRE THE BILL
AMENDED TO LIMIT MANDATE REPORT
TO THE CITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. OPERATOR THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BECAUSE BOARD OF
AB OR IN. A SEVEN EIGHTY. MR
SURELY HAVE NO CALL IN. RIGHT
THANK YOU THEN I PRETTY MAY
CLOSE ALLIANCE BRING IT TO THE
FOR QUITE OR- THE STATE THANK
YOU I WANT TO THANK FOR BRINGING
THIS UP WE DON'T. HOW HORRIFIC
IT IS WITH SECTOR RIGHT NOW AND
WE NEED EVERY HIGH IN HERE THAT
WE CAN TO GET THESE PEOPLE OFF
THE STREET THEY NEED THE HELP
AND SO I THINK THAT HAVING IN SO
THEY KNOW OF HAVING THE POLICE
SERVICES ARE SOMETIMES YOUR
FIRST RESPONDER IN IF ANYTHING
I'VE LISTENED TO THESE VICTIMS
AND THEY SAID IF IT WASN'T FOR
THEM. BEING THERE TO HELP THEM
AND GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY GET HELP AND GET OUT
THEY WON'T BE THERE SO I THINK
HAVING ALL OF THE GROUPS IN HERE
IT'S ERY IMPORTANT AND FOR THAT
I WOULD ON. A MAKE A MOTION AND-
I'D BE HONORED TO BE A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AS THEIR SECOND. A SECOND
THAT. THANK YOU WAS CUNNINGHAM
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS AND TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS I UNDERSTAND THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS HERE BUT
BUT I THINK THAT IN THESE
SITUATIONS AND WITH THAT THE
NARROWING THAT WE'VE DONE I
THINK WE HAVE AN APPROPRIATE
BILL FOR. PASSING OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTERCHAIR. SO I COULD ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION ARGUMENT MY CLOTHES.
THAT'S PER YES YOU MAY- I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY SOMETHING. THE
SAFE HARBOR KICKS IN IT THERE'S
THREE OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE TO
REPORT THIS UNDER THE BILL AS
AMENDED THEY CAN EITHER. DO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF THAT'S
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES- SAY THEY
WITNESSED SOMETHING VIOLENT YOU
WOULD WANT THEM TO CALL NINE ONE
ONE WANT THE WANT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE INVOLVED TO DE
ESCALATE SITUATION- YOU DON'T
WANT THE TROUBLE WE'RE HAVING
AND WE'RE WORKING THROUGH IT
WITH THE ACLU I THINK WE'RE-
WE'RE- WE'RE IMPROVING THE BILL
AS WE GO- YOU DON'T WANT A
SITUATION WHERE SOMEBODY
WITNESSES SOMETHING VIOLENT.
THAT IS TRAFFICKING RELATED THEY
CALL NINE ONE ONE APPROPRIATELY
BUT NOBODY CALLS THE TIP LINE OR
THE VICTIM SERVICES CENTER AND
ALL THE SUDDEN. THE HOTEL OR
MOTELS EXPOSED TO LIABILITY
THAT'S WHY THERE'S NO MANDATE
THAT YOU CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE BILL AS AMENDED YOU CAN CALL
EITHER OF THOSE THREE OPTIONS
OUR HOPE IS THAT THE FIRST CALL.
IF THERE'S NO VIOLENCE GOING ON
WOULD BE TO THE TIP LINE OR
WOULD BE TO THE VICTIM SERVICES
CENTER- I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING. THE IT LINKS UP WITH
THE TRAINING THAT THEY'RE DOING
UNDER NINE SEVENTY SO I THINK IT
MAKES SENSE- BUT I'M GONNA
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE ACLU.
AND PUT HAS BEEN. VERY HELPFUL
TO THE BILL I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF HELP INFANTS
WELL RESPECT RESTAURANT BUT-
THANK YOU. WE DO A MOTION SIR
DEMO. TO AS AMENDED CALDERON.
STONE AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE DAVIES.
DAVIES HI HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KILEY KILEY I
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES YES I RIVAS. THAT BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU RIGHT WE HAVE WE HAD A FEW
VOTES WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
WORK TO COVER SO BEAR WITH US
ALL TAKE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA CALL ROLE PLEASE
STONE I DON'T I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES. DAVIES I
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA KILEY
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN MENTION I
REYES REYES I RIVAS YOU DECIDE
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS A.
B. NINETEEN TWENTY SIX CHOI AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE LEVY AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT CHOI AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY LEVINE AND
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY ONE
CUNNINGHAM. RIGHT LET'S GO BACK
TO THE TOP OF THE AGENDA SO ITEM
NUMBER ONE. AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR LEVY STILL IN A MOTION.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE HI STONE
I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
DAVIES DAVIES I HOLDEN. HOLDEN
AYE KALRA KILEY NOW KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. REYES AYE RIVAS YOU
DECIDE THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX JONES SAWYER IS ON CALL I'M
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NO HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KILEY HIGHLY
NOW. STILL NEEDS ONE MORE I'M
GOING TO REPLACE THE CALL. THE
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY EIGHT GREG I NEED A
MOTION. THAT THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND TO THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES
. HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN. BY
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES REYES I
RIVAS RIVERSIDE THAT BILL IS OUT
. AB SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR
GIPSON IS OUT BUT WILL CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE FROM RIGHT
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY THREE
OH NINE FRIEDMAN I STILL NEED A
MOTION. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION NOW AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED HUMAN
SERVICES KALRA. STONE BY STONE I
pDAVIES I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY AYE KILEY
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MENTION I REYES.
YES I RIVAS. AS I. THANK YOU I
AM A SIX AB TWENTY FIFTY NINE IS
OUT BUT CALL THE- ABSENT MEMBERS
KALRA. KALRA ICON. KILEY NO
THANK YOU ADAM NUMBER SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS OUT
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA.
CALL RIGHT THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY I
STILL NEED A MOTION. THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES
DAVIES I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA
. KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAINTAIN AYE REYES
REYES I RIVAS RIVERSIDE. THAT
BILL IS OUT RATES GO BACK TO
CONSENT TO GENDER EQUALITY UP TO
MEMBERS KALRA. KALRA I. THE ITEM
NUMBER. KALRA KALRA I WAS AB TWO
ONE SIX FOUR ITEM NUMBER TWO IS
STILL ON CALL AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX JONES SAWYER CALL THE
UPS MEMBERS KALRA COLORI THAT
BILL IS OUT. WE'LL JUST DOUBLE
CHECK. WE HAVE EVERYBODY AND
EVERYTHING ELSE. ALL RIGHT WE DO
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND WE
ARE ADJOURNED.